road to zero our district is changing
in 2013
waimakariri's population was just under
50 000
today
around 61 000 call our district home and
it continues to grow
this means more people are using our
roads and quiet rural roads are now busy
routes
we've been residents on skewbridge road
since
2011
north canterbury is an awesome place
but there's a number of roads
in our district that have just got
unrecognizable volumes of traffic
compared to 10
or 20 or 30 years ago we'd prefer that
the speed limits were lowered and on the
skewbridge road and flexton road we
really want to change it we just feel
that if we want to live in a rural area
we have to feel safe and we don't feel
safe
we're astounded by the speed that the
cars are travelling in the noise and the
increase more importantly the increase
of traffic the hundred k's down this
road is incredibly fast
this is actually a neighbourhood a rural
neighborhood and people live here with
teenagers and toddlers personally we
know people who have actually had awful
accidents
support the lowering of the speed limit
it's only going to mean an extra 20 odd
seconds increase
to the road users we really hope that
people listen to our story
support it and make changes
we all need to work together to keep
each other safe everyone should get
where they're going safely whether
they're walking cycling
driving on a motorbike or using public
transport
[Music]